I would like to introduce this idea
professor in Technium because you talk
about taxing power it's watching thank
you thanks for watching yeah so my name
is Rita I'll talk today about how
trusted execution environments trusted
hardware and helps in the context of a
blockchain what it can what it cannot do
and I hope to raise some some
interesting questions demonstrate them
so on the face of it it seems that the
two things are kind of unrelated the
blockchain gives us this decentralized
unn permissioned replicated state
machine that clients can interact with
forming this famous log and they can
also use smart contracts to form the
wrecked peer-to-peer interactions backed
by the shared log the blockchain and
it's the same in parallel I don't know
the trusted execution environment lives
on a completely different world right
this is a guarantee you get from a
single machine inside the single machine
you have this trusted element and we
have this implemented by Intel and arm
and AMD there's some more coming up what
this gives us is the following we have
the trusted processor running on the
machine and we have some codes plus data
that that we trust we believe that this
code does what we think it does and we
trust the manufacturer of the hardware
and we don't need to trust anything else
so even the operator of the machine can
replace hardware that we don't need to
trust we don't need to trust even a
memory on that machine the operating
system may be hypervisor we don't need
to trust them or any other code that
runs on that machine and what the
guarantee we get from the processor is
confidentiality so even the operator of
the machine cannot see what's happening
inside the code and this includes a
random number generator that we're going
to use the operator of the machine
cannot affect the code with even without
seeing it so this is integrity and
finally we have remote attestation this
is critical this is the remote
attestation so this is Alice's computer
and she runs the code on the trust and
hardware and she can send an attestation
to Bob with the output from the
execution of the command a fingerprint
of the code and data fed into the
trusted processor and the signature from
Intel that this is the correct output of
running this specific code on an Intel
hardware so if you trust Intel then this
is the correct output you don't need to
trust Alice or any of this
which sounds pretty fantastic right so
we know that blockchains have some
issues on performance security
challenges and of course the
unbelievable waste of proof of work so
can trusted execution environments
simply solve all of these issues and to
quote better riches law the answer is no
and the reason is the trusted execution
environments trusted hardware have has
limitations so mostly they don't have
any IO so any access to the outside
world goes through the system operator
Alice
this means the hardware the execution
environment cannot access the blockchain
it can ask L is to put something on the
blockchain can ask Alice what's on the
blockchain but it cannot access this to
access it directly secondly individual
trusted execution environments can be
compromised arguably this is an
expensive endeavor you need microscope
and expensive but in principle it is
possible to see what's inside there and
finally T designs have vulnerabilities
as we've seen recently with foreshadow
so the the all Intel processors suddenly
became vulnerable until Intel issued fix
and we're not aware of currently of any
open open from their ability but they
arise and we need to keep it in mind
so with all of this in mind I want to to
talk about two specific projects and
we'll see how they overcome these
limitations and some open questions that
they demonstrate one project works at
the blockchain level so we're trying to
use tes to improve on blockchain
behavior and another is improving on the
second layer of payment channels this is
called teaching well start with the
first proof of useful work
so proof of proof of work as in Bitcoin
aetherium and in France uses proof of
work as follows the block proves
statistically some waste of resources in
the real world this is a capital
expenditure buying hardware for doing
proof of work and operational
expenditure your day to day expenses in
electricity etc and the point is that
the attacker must waste the similar
amount of resources in order to
successfully attack the system and
arguably this is not waste we're using
these resources to secure the system but
we would like to do better but we would
like to get that security without
wasting without without running all this
useless computation and there have been
actually quite a few suggestions around
you could run a permission system to
different model but it doesn't have the
waste you can do internal waste proof of
stake again this makes different
assumptions and produces different
guarantees but this is also an approach
there are useful resources say calculate
special specific prime a prime numbers
or store some data and prove that you
are storing it there are two issues with
this approach first of all some of these
are so for example finding specific
prime numbers is not generally agreed to
be useful and the worst issue I guess is
is that the the useful resources are
sometimes useful more to some people
than to others so if you or your
organization thinks that this is useful
your utility is going to be different
from running this then another
organization that doesn't find the
specific work to be useful so only some
people are going to mind and other or
not we're destroying the democratic and
permissionless nature of the system
so when you introduce these until this
picture you're leaving I guess I'm
moving into a model that we call
partially decentralized so we want we
want guarantees that are similar to
proof of work and anyone can join they
go to the store and they buy an Intel
processor and they can run a sketch for
example but we're adding a level of
trust we need to trust that the secure
hardware manufacturer is following the
rules and indeed Intel proposed to do
something like this in in what we call
the partially decentralized model
they're saying instead of doing the
cycles running the work do nothing just
wait for an exponential exponential
distributed amount of time like it would
happen to you with proof of work and
then your cpu will tell you if you
generated a block or you did not so this
sounds great like proof of work like
guarantees but energy no waste of energy
but there are two issues so first of the
first one is what we call the the stale
chips problem
the thing with waiting is that you could
wait with an old cheap CPU just as
efficiently as you wait with the new
cutting-edge CPU so our analysis shows
that the the Nash equilibrium epsilon
Nash in this world is that you're going
to to build these farms with old CPUs
and you're going to waste the same
amount of effort instead of on power
you'll waste it on on the hardware yeah
is the relation of should I think of it
as proof of state well my stake is the
cpu's I don't think this is equivalent
to proof of mistake because when you're
using CPUs in this way you are tying the
CPU to a specific block for mining this
is kind of similar to sorry this is kind
of similar to what happens with wind
proof of work so you cannot use the same
CPU to mine on two different blocks at
the same time technically this actually
requires some effort but this can be
enforced whereas with proof of stake in
principle if you do a naive design you
have what's known as the the what's at
stake problem right you can mine on an
any number of blocks at the same time
because you have stake on all branches
but this is brutal cpu so do this
analysis taking your camp
now you're going to increase in value of
all the CPUs we have we have not with
state of mind that the old CPU market is
significantly larger than what we expect
to be run here but this is I mean at
some point we had to make this choice
right yeah
so the second problem is the what we
call the broken chips problem so I said
earlier individual chips can in
principle be compromised and a chip that
is compromised in this way can generate
as much so called proof of work or proof
of weight as the operator wants and the
solution Intel proposed was statistic
what we also wanted to look at is there
be adverse the adversary's advantage
when doing this and the cost of the of
this test and I'll elaborate on this
later after we present our present our
solution so what what we presented was
something we called resource efficient
mining a using proof of useful work this
is joint work with fen imaging Robert
Escriva re Jules and Robert when Vanessa
from Cornell so that is the phone we're
going to dedicate not the CPUs
themselves but the work run on them for
mining we're actually going to take the
work and use it for the proof of work
but the work is going to be work that we
choose so think of it as you're running
your own workload so you're you're
optimizing for machine learning you're
looking for a cure for cancer you're
running some simulations doesn't matter
whatever you do in your lap and you
associate this work for mining this is
the go
and the challenging question is how to
measure and prove to prove this and then
force the association of the work what
we want is the following we need a
memory less memory less random
distribution that's the interval or the
time it takes you to find a solution we
need the difficulty to be tunable these
are really just the Bitcoin theorem
property right standard properties we
need all one validation right validating
the blockchain should be quick and all
the data has to be on the blockchain
there is we cannot have so you're
running your workload for machine
learning you can't expect a validator to
access your this private data in order
to validate the blockchain it has to be
small and inside the blockchain and this
is the solution we propose so all of
this is run inside what in turn calls
the Enclave this is the secure code the
trusted code you feed into it the useful
work that you need the tasks that you
need to perform and the header of the
block that you are mining on and this is
the CPU is going to run this code and
whenever there is useful output for you
useful work you're going to get that
useful output directly and it also is
going to count the the instructions that
the useful work is performing and for
every end instruction it's going to
simulate explicitly simulate and and
separate Bernoulli tests but just like
it will do with the hash function in
standard crypto currency and if at least
one of these is successful then you get
a block so the Enclave will spit out a
proof of useful work this will mean
success
you can just reduce the city or slow
mission I think this is what we're doing
right this is this is only done for the
leader election but in permissionless or
semi permissionless form so you can join
if the system works like this you can
join today you don't need a permission
system everything is run I'll talk about
the architecture very briefly later but
you you have your blockchain client
running separately and this only does
the proof of work so you don't need to
feed on the blockchain logic into this
user right so let's see what what we
actually need this is this is an actual
excellent build up so what we the output
that we get from here is the proof of
useful work so this should really be an
attestation that the Enclave was run
that it's assimilated with its internal
random engine pseudo-random engine it
simulated a Bernoulli test and one of
them won and that gives you the proof of
work so this output is really an
attestation
now you should say but you're lying you
told us that we can run we can run
anywhere and if we have Alice Bob and
Carol each of them have their own useful
work that they're performing right
they're doing difference they are doing
different things and so this output is
for a specific fingerprint so do we need
to feed all those fingerprints into
[Music]
hardcode them into the blockchain that
would defeat our purpose right
we are hard-coding the types of work
that are possible by the blockchain and
so only these types of work will be
applied and what we propose to do is
form this hierarchical station and
hierarchical attestation works as
follows so we're not authorizing
specific fingerprints we're authorizing
fingerprints of a instrumented code so
each of the participants takes their
code their useful work code and put them
through an instrumentation tool chain
and they get an enclave to execute now
we take this Enclave and we put it into
our compliance checker and the
compliance checker make sure that you
are and there are complexities there but
it makes sure that you're counting
correctly you are not cheating on the
count and that you're reporting
correctly this is done within the run
time that you're reporting correctly the
number the instruction count and it
outputs this is signed this that this
fingerprint is indeed a correctly
instrumented Enclave and now your proof
of work is actually two things that's
the only two things you're going to need
it's the at a stay the compliance
checker at the station that your code is
okay and on claims attestation that you
really did the work for the specific
for the specific block this is our tool
chain I'm not going to go through it at
all just at the end here this is the
point so the compliance checker spits
out the proof of compliance for this and
from this you get the useful work and
also proof of useful work if you're so
lucky and these two together go to the
blockchain these are not large yes yes
that's an excellent point so whoever
manufactures the hardware can now
produce all the as many at the station
as they as they like this is why we
actually need Intel so Intel's the cycle
over there make this negligible it's not
worthwhile for such a large manufacturer
to to cheat on this if you have a small
startup that is securing a blockchain
billions invited question perfect thank
you this this is our overhead so we get
some overhead from so in white it's
native it's always won and then you see
our overhead this light blue is for the
SGX overhead so they're just running the
code inside an enclave without any
instrumentation and then the dark blue
is the added
no it's just it's it's it's a batch
right right and this is the reason for
example the SVM has a high high workload
because in the SVM you see just just
from the sjx you have to enter and leave
SGX mode a lot of times and that's why
you get overhead between 5 and this is
much better than 100
seijin okay so side channels as
demonstrated in recent attacks and
famously know and even Intel say a test
in their own text that SGX in and of
itself isn't protecting you against side
channels so if you can use the side
channels to get the Enclave signing key
essentially break entirely the the SGX
then the system is broken but if you
only have visibility into what's running
you cannot affect in principle you
cannot affect the code so you will be
able to see that you will need so many
sorry you'll be able to see I guess
before the SJ X tells you whether or not
you won the block but you want to be
able to affect your chances we only roll
the dice at the end after we know how
many instructions were counted yeah
there are no no no secrets apart from
the random number this by the way there
is another difference from Intel's proof
of elapsed time because there you have
to roll the dice at the beginning and it
tells you you have one hour until your
block and there if you don't if you have
visibility inside the SGX and you don't
like that number you can terminate it
and start again
that possible to wish to the trust for
integrity in some way so that if one our
trade is a factory speculative
yeah that's an interesting that's an
interesting point we have not done this
here at all and maybe maybe we'll keep
it for for an offline discussion but
I'll talk a little bit about this later
on in another context
okay very briefly about the broken chip
problem so say you got that that
expensive Microsoft and you compromised
your own chip and now you're able to
attest to anything so you're not able to
create many fake chips all the Intel
will be able to do that but you'll be
able to create as many at the stations
as you like for blocks without doing any
work so what we did is we created a
statistical likelihood tests that
rejects blocks from the same CPU if they
commit to high frequency trying to
produce blocks to high frequency or
blocks will get rejected if we're too
permissive the Intel attacker gains
right if we are not being strict the
attacker can make many blocks and make a
lot more money than they're supposed to
if we're too restrictive it means that I
mean there's always some chance that
someone might get lucky the fritter
restrictive where we're causing them to
lose money and more importantly we're
reducing the security of the system
because you're just throwing down the
drain good work
here's our analysis we see the this is a
simulation run over the course of
simulating course of 60 days and you see
here in red the advantage of the
attacker this is yeah
how many more blocks in percent are able
to create over time in the beginning our
statistical test is not very reliable
because it doesn't have enough data and
so we rely allowing a lot more blocks
than we would have liked to but over
time it goes down in a towards towards
one and is able to correctly reject
blocks which means that it's not
worthwhile for you to spend all this
money on the microscope over time it
won't be worth it
we've got only a few more blocks and
this is the inverse of that how much
work is wasted with with the same
statistical test so again we're looking
at how many blocks we're rejecting
because someone got too lucky
initially the statistical test is not
very accurate but over time and we're
rejecting blocks very infrequently we
have a long term statistic
the blue line is the aggregate number of
rejected books perhaps who could have
used the different statistical tests the
one we use for the one we used it was it
was a bit too it was a bit too
restrictive in the beginning
yes I guess my bottom my bottom line
here is that using SG axes for blocks
for securing an actual blockchain is a
delicate issue and it only applies in
specific contexts so not for your
general public crypto currency for
example it's too dangerous
there's also the issue of a wide
compromise like the one we've seen
recently for Intel this I believe is
more practical context which is payment
channels among users of the blockchain
so this is the story of payment channels
you all heard this so each each user of
the blockchain places a deposit
transaction on the blockchain and then
they're able to pay one another directly
and each can unilaterally terminate the
channel they're done place a transaction
on the blockchain that gives them
whatever they're owed the basic
structure for a unidirectional Channel
is the following we have a less pain Bob
Alice places the setup transaction
everything below the blue line is on the
blockchain everything above the blue
line is not on the blockchain but can be
placed on the blockchain if there are
sufficiently many signatures so Alice
gets this refund transaction that is
time locked after say one month if Bob
disappears she can place it on the
blockchain and get her money this is not
the desired scenario what we're trying
to do is a payment channel so with the
payment Channel what happens is that say
Alice wants to pay three dollars to Bob
she creates this transaction that pays
Bob three dollars out of her deposit of
$100 and since the ninety seven back to
Alice this requires two signatures from
Alice and from Bob
Alice only gives her own signature on
that and the Bob if he chooses to spend
this to terminate the to settle the
channel at this state can add his
signature and place this on the
blockchain but we keep the channel open
and then Alice wants to pay two more
dollars to Bob so she creates a new
updated settlement transaction again
signed only by herself and Bob can
settle this now he gets five three plus
two and Alice gets back 1995 Alice
cannot place this old transaction back
on the chain because she doesn't have
Bob's signature and Bob will naturally
choose the latest transaction because it
gives him the most money
so now we're interested in doing a be
directional channel each party can
should be able to settle the channel at
any time but a party cannot roll the
channel back so Ellis cannot pay Bob and
then settle the channel at the states
before she paid one so here's a naive
solution to do that
just unidirectional channels each of
them place a deposit and they pay one
another we have to be directional
channel only it's not terribly efficient
see here LS paid 100 and Bob pays back
50 now Alice is supposed to be able to
pay more to Bob but she cannot because
she depleted her channel so this is not
what we want we'll have to go back to
the blockchain and start a new
unidirectional Channel this is not what
we're looking after and so there is a
solution to that without trusted
execution environment the most famous
instantiation of it is the Lightning
Network proposed by full Nvidia back in
2016 and the idea of this and most other
other similar solutions is to do state
updates so what's a payment in this
world a payment is a capability of the
receiver to close the channel or settle
the channel at the current state and
also it is a capability to take all the
money punished penalize the other party
if they try to settle at an older state
listen when I receive the money I get
these two capabilities but there is a
catch right how do we do this so this is
easy this is a signed transaction
settling the current state right they
produce it together with other
signatures but how do we do this
so I also when I receive the money I
also get a secret and the secret will
nullify a deprecated settlement from the
other side so Bob gets a secret from
Alice and you can use the secret if
Alice tries to settle in older and older
states on the blockchain which means
that actually this one is a portable
with a secret so I get Bob gets assigned
transaction settling the current state
that is a portable with the secret
and the catch of all these solutions is
that they require so there there's
there's a lot of work on such channels
and state channels and your land
generalization of this but generally
this is the idea and all of these
solutions require real-time blockchain
access right if we want to be able to
abort a transaction it means that once
the transaction is placed on the
blockchain there is a time interval and
during this time interval the
transaction can be aborted and after
this time interval the transaction
cannot be aborted only block chains are
not real-time right and we have a
demonstration from Bitcoin this is the
time it play it takes to place a
transaction on the Bitcoin network over
a few months and you see that the
confirmation time has even reached days
so we cannot honestly rely on a time
limit on a time limited settlement
requirement we can I mean it becomes a
very practical discussion right we can
make the intervals very long and then we
have issue of locked-in funds until the
finest hours this is the time it takes
for you to place a transaction on the
blockchain
so someone issue the transaction it goes
into the peer-to-peer network and it is
not placed on the blockchain because the
blockchain is full it waits in line and
it waits in line between an hour and
many hours so this is not the time for a
block to be buried inside the chain
that's about one hour always this is the
average this is average confirmation
time I believe
between time they were placed on the
time yeah so our goal is to avoid this
this real time requirement using trusted
execution environments and we're going
to we're going to get some additional
benefits so let's take off the sorry
this is a joint work with Josh Lynn
florian Calbert and Peter pizza at
Imperial College London my student all
didn't know at the Technion and I mean
goons here at Cornell and Josh will
present this in SSP next week so first
of all let's take the strumming story
off the table I mean the the trusted
execution environment is not a trusted
third party right if we had the trusted
third party whoo Alice and Bob would
just give them the trusted third party
their funds and the trusted third party
would take care of everything but this
is not the story of the third party this
is the story of the third party there is
some Carol sitting between Alice and Bob
and the trusted execution environment
and Carol can say okay I'm holding your
your funds until you pay me something or
it can crash and have the problem so
this this is this is not a viable
solution instead what we propose is the
following structure so each of Alice and
Bob has their own trusted execution
environment and managed separately and
they move their funds to the control of
their teas so they pay their teas and
the teas control the funds of the
channel completely now what do the t's
actually give us here they give us the
guarantee that they only they will only
create a settlement transaction once
this this is the issue this is what we
needed
they will not create a depth they will
not give that the alice is te will not
give Alice a settlement for a deprecated
state
how do we achieve this I'll first
describe the protocol briefly and then
talk about correctness and then some
performance so the to tes form a secure
channel this is a bit more elaborate
than the SSP version they create a
direct channel between one another
through the their operators Alice and
Bob so they really do a diffie-hellman
handshake terminated inside the G using
at the stations that are validated
inside the TV
so the process is falling first of all
they need to deposit some money into the
blockchain right so Ellis pays her te
right this is money that goes from Alice
to her T and she has multiple such
deposits now she tells her te this is my
deposit and it's on the blockchain note
that the TE cannot validate this right
the T doesn't have direct access to the
blockchain doesn't know but we don't
need that that's fine now Alice and Bob
decided to open a channel let's call it
the red Channel they do the same shake
story and then Ellis tells what
instructor abomb and instructs her te to
produce a message to Bob saying these
are the transactions that belong to me
now
Bob receives this he gets the guarantee
from the TE that these funds are really
secure by keys that are inside the T and
Bob can go to the blockchain and see
that they really are on the blockchain
and he's motivated to do that because
it's his money at stake is going to bed
steak
this yeah and this happened and now this
deposit is associated to this channel
and the TV will not allow Ellis to use
this deposit for anything else but let
alone let alone take it out
now when Ellis wants to do a payment and
this is a state with multiple associated
deposits Ellis just needs to send a
single message to Bob a payment message
Bob sees this payment message message
sent from the te and now this message is
the guarantee that the TE will not
generate a settlement for an older state
that's all that he needs there is no
time sensitivity on settlement HT
produces the transaction to take money
of all relevant deposits to both sides
it's quite simple and then it stops it
will not produce another settlement and
interestingly we can do something that
we could not do before the deposits are
not locked into the channel ad infinitum
but only if they're necessary so if
Alice had the deposit a3 associated with
a red channel and then she doesn't need
it because Ellis paying sorry Bob paid
more than she did she can dissociate the
deposit from the channel this is a
process she's doing with Bob
she needs Bob permission that he doesn't
need this deposit anymore and if he
fails then she can settle she can always
settle the channel the previous day but
otherwise everything if everything went
well then she can now take this deposit
and use it elsewhere this is important
this is less transactions going to the
blockchain
so importantly once the once the
deposits are on the blockchain we don't
need any blockchain access in order to
form a channel perform payments and even
release deposits if we're balanced out
so everything is very quick this is the
instant instant payment in the sense
that we don't need blockchain access
we're only limited by the latency
between the two parties now let's talk
about correctness the the first task is
of course to define what we mean by
correctness so first we define perceived
balance perceived balance is what each
party thinks they have it's their
initial balance plus whatever they got
minus whatever they paid we also define
blockchain balance this is the balance
that the blockchain believes each party
has blockchain is its own entity and for
correctness we want the user to be able
to move her perceived balance to the
blockchain terribly formally here but
our proof is simulation based so we're
using T and blockchain is a function of
the function functionalities and we
create this functionality of the TE of
the T chain and then we show that the T
chain actually maintains the blockchain
and challenge channel balances and the
ideal world execution are
indistinguishable from the real world so
in the interest of time I think I'm
going to skip this element and assume we
already have this teaching ideal
functionality we wanted to show again
that each part is able to receive what
she should have on the blockchain so we
do this constructively we write down
this this algorithm that takes the money
off all channels and this is a bit
tedious but it works out so it settles
all the channels depending on what state
each channel was and then moves it back
into the blockchain out outside the
deposit so we first prove that the
protocol indeed
specifically if Ellis wants to do this
Bob cannot do any operation that would
prevent Ellis from completing the
protocol one way or another that we show
that the functionality maintains the
invariants the perceived balance of an
entity equals her what we call actual
balance we define an actual balance that
is the combination of her balance on the
blockchain and her balance on the chain
on the payment channels and then we show
that after completion the actual which
is actually also the perceived is
actually present on the blockchain
now a few words about failures
so we trust that Intel is not going to
risk their their annual revenue for for
attacking the system but this trusted
execution environment has all our money
inside it and if we run out of battery
power failure then we lose it all
desirable and the know if solution would
be to do a backup right and we ask that
EE to produce this backup we put it on
our hard drive and then if we lose power
we load it again if we do this naively
then this opens the door to a natural
replay attack with the Ellis space bar
sorry
generates a backup pays Bob shutdown
shuts down her machine boot boot straps
from the state before the payment and
goes to settle the the channel and have
the Lamborghini and her money as well
instead what we do is so I'll offer you
two two solutions to this one is
monotonic counters so Intel provides in
most of its motherboards the ability to
use monotonic counters meaning that
there is a counter that is controlled it
is secured controlled by the SGX that is
only increasing so we increment it on
each backup on each store of the state
and we only and this incremental counter
is maintained through reboots
and so if we reboot and the incremental
counter the monotony counter is not
where it should be then we don't lo it
don't it this is mostly final it's very
slow so the hardware only allows ten of
these every second takes point 0.1
second to run this and so this is good
if I'm doing it from my laptop and I do
a few payments a day but if there are
two exchanges that want to do a frequent
payments among one another for arbitrage
or whatever this is not an applicable
solution or or they can take a risk like
it
hundred millisecond risk
I might have been I don't know that I
think that this this is based on this on
this approach I don't think that there's
anything particularly interesting here
right you have to allow for this yeah
you have a short interval but that's not
a lot of time so you're reducing your
risk
so the solutions I think is actually
more interesting is the is the following
this requires admittedly a lot a lot
more resources though what we do is we
produce this chain of tes so 3t is
running on separate machines with a
different failure modes and each command
goes through all the machines so this is
like a classical chain replication for
storage right only here this is not
about storage we do want to keep in
throughput and we're giving up some
latency like in storage but here in case
of failure we are doing something a bit
different so say we're running through
these three T's and one of them or two
of them fail we have just one T in
remaining what we can do here and what
we have to do here is at this point
settle the channel we replicate as much
as we want for security but once the
chain breaks we cannot allow for
continued payments because that would
allow for for a clever attacker to chop
it in a in a in a careful way and then
let some portion advance in order to
produce payment and another remain in
the old state in order to settle at the
deprecated state so what one wants one
of them fail we go back we settle the
channel at the state that is maintained
in the CPU this requires a lot more
resources so this is not for me running
on my laptop this is for for the
exchange in a scenario where
the stakes are sufficiently high to
justify running this and energy
replicated way so we actually try this
we opened the channel between Imperial
College London and Cornell and we made
some payments we had either one backup
or no backup
and this is the measurements we got from
lightning to lightening the batches its
transactions so you have to they
accumulate as you see here over a
certain time and then they are placed in
a transaction that is placed we don't
have to have batching but but we can and
you see the significant increase in
throughput mainly because we don't in
order to complete a payment we don't
need to do any more or much more than
just send a single message from one side
to another there is a significant
overhead as you see here when we have to
go across the Atlantic again for a chain
for chain replication if you want this
if you want this mechanism right we get
a significant significantly higher
latency
my own time
that's perfect
one last interesting point about all of
this is multi-hop payments
I legit I get the file you should finish
okay I'm sorry
so I will not talk about multi-hop but
I'll be glad to tell you about it if
you're interested demonstrates the the
curiosity of interaction between
between trusted execution environments
and blockchains and since I'm out of
time I'm going to just leave this here
and thank you very much over asking
these questions
yeah